centre d'hébergement des mortem à
Versailles ce midi ce centre fait partie
du dispositif péren ouvert toute l'année
dans le département 1118 places
d'urgence proposé mais en période
hivernale 349 places se rajoutent et le
plan de prévention est renforcé selon la
température depuis ce jeudi le
département est passé en niveau 2 sur 3
possible ce qui implique un renforcement
des outils il implique une augmentation
des
places qui sont donc ouvertes il
implique un renforcement des maraudes
pour à la fois la Croix-Rouge le l'Ordre
de Malte et les marudes communal il
implique une ouverture plus grande des
abris de jour on envoit plusieurs mail
successifs dans les journées comme
celle-ci pour faire le tour de toutes
les structures et on va jusqu'à ouvrir
des places assises si jamais vraiment il
y avait un manque de place en lit ce
niveau 2 sera maintenu jusqu'à mardi
matin le 115 le numéro d'appel d'urgence
est lui très sollicité dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi le service a reçu 276
appels et nouveauté depuis une semaine
tous les appels sont vérifié même ceux
qui n'aboutissent pas et toutes les
personnes recontactées c'est ce que le
115 a fait hier soir jusqu'à 23h30 hier
c'était pour la première fois depuis la
période hivernale c'était tendu et les
appels ont été tardifs c'està-dire en
fait à partir de 19h quand les gens ont
commencé à sentir vraiment le froid
intense le 115 peut dans ce cas faire le
choix d'ouvrir des places d'hébergement
dans les hôtels le département connaît
l'arrivée d'un nouveau type de
population des habitants de la petite
couronne parisienne et de plus en plus
de familles avec
enfants